hi there Steve Kaufman here again I want
to follow up on my last video and I want
to talk about words and word families in
my last video I said we can learn 100
words a day depending on circumstances
if it's a very different language it
might only be 20 words a day that as we
get into the language we pick up more
and more words incidentally without
because we don't necessarily need to
look them up and on a system like link
if we don't look a word up it's assumed
that we know the word again if we come
across the word again and we don't know
it now in a new context we can look it
up again and the statistics adjust but
and I encourage people not to try and
learn one or two words a day and very
deliberately try and learn them but
rather that the strategy should be to do
as much listening and reading as
possible so that you start getting that
snowballing effect of accumulating more
and more words you know incidentally
naturally now obviously this assumes
that you are either reading material
which has word lists which is what I
used to do and I learn Chinese and other
languages or you're reading at least in
the early stages a lot on a computer
where you have access to online
dictionaries such as is the case at link
you can't just start reading I mean you
have to have access to a dictionary and
quick access to a dictionary because as
we all know no sooner do you look
something up in a dictionary then you
forget it and so you have to very
quickly get some meaning continue
reading do some listening forget it go
back in there and so forth so now the
there were a number of comments saying
yeah you can learn how to words a day if
you're only talking about words but
really we should be talking about word
families and I get this discussion
argument quite frequently and I don't
agree first of all let me say that some
languages will have you know more words
by nature of the fact that they are
no inflected that-there's conjugations
and declensions and so forth so whereas
in English we go I go you go he goes we
go you go they go in French vive la la
la evolve their six forms so on the same
Slavic languages with their nouns and
their adjectives so the numbers will be
larger but that doesn't matter because
I'm not comparing my known words between
languages I'm just treating the known
words number as as milestones in my
pursuit of this language and I've said
before that pursuing your known words
total say at link is kind of like the
you know the racing greyhounds pursuing
the mechanical rabbit it's something
that inspires you to go forward and if
you acquire more words eventually you're
gonna be able to use them now one other
problem with with words number of things
with word families why I prefer to count
every every different form of a word as
a different word okay the easiest sort
of example of where you shouldn't get
credit for you shouldn't get credit for
car and cars okay it's the same word you
see car you see cars however it's not
obvious in every language how plurals
are formed and so it might be worthwhile
even in English to save oxen as the
plural form of ox you still need to
learn that it's oxen that's point number
one and this occurs in a number of
different languages the different cases
in different languages like Slavic
languages they're governed very often by
prepositions or by certain verbs and
therefore it's useful to save and to
learn the different forms of say a noun
and and save that together with the
preposition or the verb that governs it
and so I find myself saving a lot of
different forms and learning therefore a
lot of different forms of adjectives and
nouns individually and as part of
phrases so I do need to deliberately or
these
pay attention to the different forms so
to that extent the statistics that count
the number of individual words that I
have learned is a meaningful statistic
furthermore you know how do we define
word family so in English you know just
thinking of words like I don't know I
mentioned the last time the word act so
act acted okay that's pretty easy that's
the past tense maybe you shouldn't get
credit for that you might pass that over
in your at your you know padding your
known word number but action maybe is
something that you need to save more
deliberately if you see an activity
reaction you know nation alright Nations
okay that's obvious nationality it's not
so obvious is that part of the same word
family or not international so
international you know in say Slavic
language mesh do not need or verbal
forms of that between nations is how you
say international that's not immediately
obvious so when I see that either I
deduce it from the context in which case
I get credit for it or I might save it I
mean the same is true in Chinese where
all of they're not all but the majority
of your words are count compounds of two
and sometimes three characters so you
can at times deduce the meaning although
sometimes you can fool yourself so I
would tend to look it up just to make
sure and so you very quickly accumulate
in Chinese vocabulary based on you know
you know guide yen is to change guy gin
is to improve sue guy is to revise guy
Shan is to improve so you start to see
these words that contain a character
that you're very familiar with another
character that you're familiar with you
haven't seen them in combination you see
it you assume you know what it is or you
look it up but very quickly you can
count that as known because it's so
familiar that you you tend to remember
it so the point I'm making is that you
know in counting the words
okay I'm not trying to say if I like my
statistics that link tell me got 90,000
words in Russian 60,000 words in Czech
40,000 words in Korea this is not
something I can brag about but these are
milestones and if I can drive that known
word total in Korean up to 60,000 I
think I'll be able to understand you
know news and so forth much better than
I do now it's been my experience the
higher my known words total the better I
understand the better I understand
eventually the better I speak and of
course I have to at some point start
speaking a lot if I want to be able to
speak well but if I don't have a base in
vocabulary if I don't have a a good
level of vocabulary and comprehension
skills I won't be able to develop
speaking skills some people say well
there's no one knows that many words and
stuff like that look up in Wikipedia the
size of dictionaries around the world
and most of them are well over a hundred
thousand words up to you know five
hundred thousand words I mean there are
a lot of words in these different
languages and there are constantly new
words being added so the assumption
again that the well if I have five
thousand words I cover 90% of any
content is another common fallacy the
idea that a small number of words
accounts for you know 90% 80% of any
context that may be so however it has
been my experience that the words you
really need the key words for any given
context are amongst those infrequent
words and those infrequent words are
hard to learn for the simple reason that
they're infrequent that yet they are
quite key I have only to look at my
experience at link I can if I know
20,000 30,000 words and I bring in an
article or ebook into link I still have
a lot of unknown words the percentage
may be low but there's a lot of them and
they are quite key to understand the
context
so to summarize people can count words
however they want they can count word
families if they can come up with it you
know clear sort of definition of
constitutes a word family maybe such a
thing exists I don't know I see no harm
in counting every single sort of
different occurrence of the word as a
separate word maybe it pads your
statistics a little bit that might
encourage you it doesn't detract from
your learning in any way and in many
cases you know learning let's say the
instrumental case of the word you know
Dulce ami in Russian is different you
need to learn that because it's not
obvious and so every form of the word to
my mind is worth learning that's why we
count them the way we do and so that's
just to respond to some of the points
that were raised in response to my last
video so thanks for listening bye for
now
[Music]
you
[Music]